Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Me llaman el cazador de tornados.
Cuando se levanta el viento
y se dan las condiciones óptimas
subo al auto y sigo tormentas violentas.
"Loco", dirás. Quizá, pero persigo
estas bestias del cielo
para aprender de ellas.
Quiero compartir con Uds. lo que sé.
Los tornados son columnas
de aire que giran rápidamente
y se forman dentro de las tormentas
que se conectan con la tierra
a través de un embudo de nubes.
Cuando eso sucede, arrasan la Tierra,
planteando una gran amenaza
para la vida y la propiedad.
Por eso se investiga tanto
estos fenómenos,
pero la verdad es que todavía hay mucho
que no sabemos sobre cómo se forman.
Las condiciones que generan un tornado
no necesariamente generarán otro.
Pero hemos aprendido mucho
desde que empezamos a registrarlos,
aprendimos a reconocer los signos
de que se están gestando en el cielo.
¿Vendrás de paseo?
Empiezan con una tormenta eléctrica,
pero no cualquiera.
Se llaman supercélulas;
son especialmente poderosas y se elevan.
Llegan hasta más de 15 000 metros,
traen fuertes vientos,
super granizos, a veces inundaciones
y grandes relámpagos también.
Estos son los tipos de tormentas
que generan tornados,
pero solo si se dan
condiciones específicas,
pistas que podemos medir y buscar
al tratar de pronosticar una tormenta.
El aire que se eleva
es el primer ingrediente
necesario para la formación de un tornado.
Una tormenta se forma
si ocurre una condensación,
efecto de las nubes.
La condensación libera calor,
y el calor se transforma en la energía
que impulsará los enormes corrientes
ascendentes de aire.
Cuanto más condensación
y más grande la tormenta,
más poderosos se vuelven
esas nubes de tormenta.
En las supercélulas, esta masa de aire
ascendente es particularmente fuerte.
Conforme sube el aire, puede cambiar
de dirección y moverse más rápidamente.
Por último, en la base de la tormenta,
si hay mucha humedad,
se desarrolla una enorme base
de nubes, dándole al tornado
algo de que alimentarse después,
si llega tan lejos.
Cuando confluye todo esto, puede
desarrollarse un vórtice en la tormenta,
y formar un tubo de aire alto y ancho
que gira y luego asciende.
A esto le llamamos un mesociclón.
El aire exterior, frío, seco, que baja
empieza a colocarse en la parte posterior
del mesociclón,
formando lo que se conoce como descendente
de los flancos traseros.
Este escenario inusual crea
una diferencia de temperatura
entre el aire interno del mesociclón,
y el aire exterior,
creando un nivel de inestabilidad
que permite que prospere un tornado.
Luego, la parte inferior del mesociclón
se vuelve más fuerte,
aumentando la velocidad del viento.
Si, y este es un gran si, este embudo
de aire se mueve hacia abajo
en esa gran base nubosa húmeda
de la parte inferior de la tormenta madre,
la succiona y se vuelve
un muro de nubes giratorio
formando un enlace entre la tormenta
que lo creó y la Tierra.
Ni bien el tubo de nubes
giratorias toca el suelo,
se convierte en un tornado.
La mayoría son pequeños, de corta duración
produciendo vientos de 100 a 200 km/h,
pero otros pueden durar más de una hora,
produciendo vientos de 300 km/h.
Son hermosos, pero aterradores,
sobre todo si tú o tu ciudad
se interpone en su camino.
En ese caso, nadie,
ni siquiera cazadores de tornados como yo,
disfrutan viendo el desarollo de eso.
Como todo, sin embargo,
los tornados llegan a su fin.
Cuando la diferencia de temperatura
desaparece
y las condiciones son más estables,
o se seca la humedad del aire,
la feroz tormenta madre pierde impulso
y atrae a su tornado hacia adentro.
Aún así, los meteorólogos y cazadores
de tormentas como yo seguiremos al acecho,
mirando, siempre mirando, para ver
si la tormenta libera
su largo cebo de nuevo.